checklist item number 45.
uh do you know
what to outsource to freelancers and how
to outsource the freelancers this is
critical um
there are things that will take
a lot of work
a lot of time but they're not strategic
if it's administrative repeatable
one-time outsourcing what's an example
of that well
we needed to research all the founders
in australia
and so i went on fiverr i shouldn't say
i want a high fiver one of my team
members went to five we hired two
different people we said hey here's a
database make us a database read the
news in australia do google searches for
startup founders use crunchbase use
pitch book use anything you can
look at the find us all the accelerators
look on their portfolio page
find us on twitter every australian
startup put them into this database try
to guess the person's email confirm the
email because we want to invite them to
come to launch festival australia
and man we started on third base i could
have had my internal people do it but i
wanted them picking the speakers finding
a location uh and um
doing the marketing
now
you
might be able to hire a freelancer to
find locations you might be able to
crowdsource that
sales building product
probably not a good idea product
customers team right that's what i talk
about with this flywheel product
customers team
don't outsource
recruiting customers and product
anything in there is kind of a secret
sauce right those are the three
legs of your stool
you rip off customers you rip off
product rip buff team the stool falls
over if you have an outsourced product
team building they're not full-time they
don't they're not dedicated to you they
work on a project basis
that might be fine for building your mvp
but honestly it's a major red flag like
10 red flags if you can't build the
product in-house because every investor
knows we give you 250k you give it to
your outsourced development firm and
then development stops okay give you
500k give it to your outsourced
development you got to have that
in-house
same thing with customers if you're not
talking to your customers and somebody
else is selling them you've abstracted
that layer that's why all those rep
firms that called in the early days of
this week in startups and said hey can
we sell your ads i said no
i want to have a sales team i want to
know who the
advertisers are on the podcast i want to
meet the advertisers myself i actually
do onboarding calls with each advertiser
which is kind of intense given how many
we have now but i still try to do at
least an on-boarding call with them
so they know me
i can let them know i appreciate them i
can hear from them what their goals are
and it just increases renewal so even i
take uh this hard medicine of really
getting to know the customers even
though it's time consuming and let's
face it you know a lot of other
podcasters think they're above it like i
don't think you know every podcaster of
note or of my stature is getting on
calls with advertisers i i still do it
i'm gonna try to keep doing
team same thing you know
no offense to headhunters please don't
start emailing me but
you know if you're outsourcing head
hunting it means you don't have a great
culture it means you don't have
a company that people want to work for
it means your mission is not good and
you're probably going to get people who
are not great hires you need to have
that muscle internally
work that muscle internally get good at
it product customers team in-house that
everything else outside
hr tools
gusto i mean amazing they just get
everything done for you
these peos etc uh rippling
zenfits all these places are great at
that outsourced accounting tons of
places to do that for you and
you know with outsourced uh services
the people look at that as efficiency
you don't need to rack your own service
you don't need to build your own hr
department
uh until you hit
you know massive scale and even then hr
you want to bring in house probably 50
100 people is what i hear from most
founders
and building your own server form
unless there's some super compelling
reason to do it you're probably not
going to be able to compete with
google cloud or azure or everybody else
trying to lower the cost of doing that
okay
item number 46 on our checklist how much
do you pay early employees do you know
how to manage your bankroll and not have
to pay a fortune
you are going to be unable if you're a
seed funded company to
compete against
google and facebook you should not try
when you're interviewing somebody and
they say hey i have a google deal hey
this is my linkedin deal here's my
microsoft deal you just have to say to
them we can't compete with that if
you're going for max money you should go
work there if you're going for max
impact you should work here and
immediately sort them out of your
process
immediately i literally had a founder
say hey this person's got a competing
deal with google how do we compete i
said you don't
you don't
if that person wants max money just tell
them this is not max money you're going
to make half as much cash comp and
you're going to get you know the chance
of getting the lottery ticket at options
of a company that's currently valued at
10 or 20 million dollars or 50 million
or 100 million
if you want to go work on making
you know billions of people click on
facebook ads 0.001
time go ahead if you want to change the
world
please do that here
that's the difference do not try to
compete against those now you want to do
the best you can and so what you could
say is listen we are seed funded
we've raised a million dollars
we know as a developer you can get 200
250 working at that company we can offer
you 150 or 125. you're a salesperson you
can make 150 working at twilio for your
base salary and then get two percent of
sales to get you to 250k i can pay you
75k but i'll give you 10 of sales for
the first year and we'll see in year two
so
you know 10 on 500k or a million would
be 50 to 100k you get 125 but we want
you to give you stock options and you
can grow from that so
i think you have to be creative and then
when you get funded with more money you
can go back and remember those
conversations and give people raises and
you can be much more aggressive in your
raises when you start raising more money
uh and
uh if people are going for max money you
just have to accept in the startup world
that you will not be able to compete
period end of story and don't try to
you can always also look for if this
person's a vp of sales and you can't get
them to leave
some sas company doing 100 million in
revenue who's two
steps below that person is there a sales
executive who wants to be the sales
manager is there a sales manager who
wants to be your vp of cells that's the
way to do it is you you take somebody
who's the sixth seventh eighth player on
the basketball team but not in the
starting five and you say we believe you
should be a starter on our team you'll
be a starter so sometimes in the nba
they'll say hey this person is going to
go to this team to chase a ring or to be
on a team with a winning record of this
person is going to go to a team because
they want to be the man and have the
ball in their hands and be starting and
playing 40 minutes so they're they're
picking the team not based on how much
they can get paid all things being equal
they're picking it based on the role
that's what you're looking to do is find
people who want to be the man
or that's in the case of the nba or the
woman in the case of wnba who want to
shoot their shot right and who want to
get more minutes on the court and that's
what you're selling and if people are
mercenaries and they want to go for
money just cut them off immediately we
can't compete with google where our
offer is going to be on a cash
compensation basis far below google
and then stop talking and see what they
say and they say oh i need to make
max cash can you match them you say
there is no way we can match them period
end of story
okay sock two